- [Voiceover] Hey guys,
so in the last video
I was talking about how
you can define a function
whose graph is a plane,
and moreover a plane that
passes through a specified point
and whose orientation
you can somehow specify.
And we ended up seeing how
specifying that orientation
comes down to certain partial
derivative information.
And first let me just kind of
repeat what the conclusion was
but I'll put it in more abstract terms
since I did it in a very
specific example last time.
So basically if you want
some kind of function
which gives you a plane that
passes through a certain point.
Well first let's see
what that point is right.
Let's say the point was x
nought, y nought, and z nought.
So these are constant values
and this is my way of
abstractly describing
a single point in space using
x nought to represent a constant x value,
y nought to represent constant
y value, that kind of thing.
So what it is, is it's gonna
be some sort of other constant
a multiplied by x minus x nought.
So this white x here is the variable
and then x nought is just a constant.
Now let me go ahead and
make that parentheses there.
Then we add to that b multiplied by
and then b is just some other constant
just like a is some other constant
multiplied by y minus y nought
and then all of that you add z nought.
And now if you were just
presented this as it is
it's kind of a lot right,
there's five different constants going on.
But really what this is saying is
you want something where
the partial derivative
with respect to x is just some constant
and you want to be able to
specify what that constant is.
And similarly, the partial derivative
with respect to y is another constant.
And you just want to ensure that this
passes through this point
x nought, y nought, z nought.
And if you imagine plugging in
x the variable equals x nought
the constant this part goes to zero.
Similarly plugging in y nought the constant
makes this part go to zero.
So this is a way of
specifying that when you
evaluate the function x
nought y nought equals z nought,
and that's what makes sure that the graph
passes through that point.
So with that said let's
start thinking about
how you can find the
tangent plane to a graph.
And first of all let's think
about what that point is,
how you specify such a point.
Instead of specifying any
three numbers in space,
because you have to make sure the point
is somewhere on the graph,
you instead only specify two.
You're basically gonna say
what's the x coordinate
and in this case let's say
the x coordinate was one,
and then the y coordinate which
looks about like negative two.
To make it easier I'm just
gonna say it is negative two.
Then the z coordinate is specified
because this is a graph.
Z coordinate is forced
to be whatever the output
of the function is at one negative two.
So this is gonna be whatever
the output of our function is
at one negative two.
And f here, f is going to be whatever
function gives us this graph.
So maybe I should write
down the actual function
that I'm using for this graph.
In this case f which is
a function of x and y
is equal to three minus one third
of x squared minus y squared.
So this is the function that we're using
and you evaluate it at that point
and this will give you your
point in three dimensional space
that our linear function,
that our tangent plane
has to pass through.
So we can start writing
out our linear function.
We can say okay so our linear function
has a function of x and y.
It's gotta make sure it goes through
that one and that negative two,
so this is gonna be some constant a
that we'll fill in in a moment,
multiplied by x minus that one,
plus and then b also a constant
we'll specify in a moment,
times y minus that negative two,
so it's minus a negative two
and then the thing that we add to it
is f of one negative two.
Now let's just go ahead and evaluate that.
Let's say we plug in one to negative two.
So if we go up here and we plug
in three minus one third of
if x equals one, one third of one squared,
so that's one third one squared,
and then y is negative two.
So that would be minus
negative two squared.
So that's three minus a third minus four
so the whole thing is equal to
three minus four is negative
one minus another third
is negative four thirds.
So that's what we add
to this entire thing.
We add negative four thirds
or maybe I should just kind of
make clear the separation here.
So this is our function but we
don't know what a and b are.
Those are things that we need to plug in.
Now the whole idea of the tangent plane
is that the partial
derivative with respect to x
should match that of
the original function.
So if we go over to the graph here
and start thinking about
partial derivative information.
If we want the partial
derivative with respect to x
then you imagine moving purely
in the x direction here.
This intersects the graph
along some kind of curve
and what the partial
derivative with respect to x
at this point tells you, is
the slope of the tangent line,
in that direction of that point.
So that's what the partial
derivative with respect to x
is telling you and what
you want when you look
at the tangent plane is
that the tangent plane
also has that same slope.
If I lined things up here,
you'd want it also to
have that same slope.
So you can specify over here and say a.
You want a to be equal
to the partial derivative
of the function with respect to x
evaluated at this one negative two.
Evaluated at that special
point, one negative two.
And similarly b for pretty
much the same reasons
and I'll draw it out here
so let's erase this line.
So instead of intersecting
it with that slice
let's see what movement in
the y direction looks like.
So in this case it looks
like a very steep slope right
because in this case the
tangent line in that direction
is a pretty steep slope
and now when we bring in
the tangent plane it
should intersect with that
constant x value plane
along that same slope.
Made it kind of messy there
but you can see the line formed
by intersecting these two planes
should be that desired tangent,
and what that corresponds to in formulas
is that this b which represents
the partial derivative of l,
l is the tangent plane function,
that should be the same as if
we took the partial derivative
of f with respect to y at that point,
at this point one negative two.
And this is stuff that we can compute
and that we can figure out.
So let's start plugging that in.
First let me just copy this function
because we're gonna need it.
Now let's go on down here.
I'm just gonna, let's paste it down here
in the bottom because
that's what we'll need.
So let's compute the
partial derivative of f
with respect to x.
So we look down here, the
only place where x shows up
is in this negative one
third of x squared context
so the partial derivative
of f with respect to x
is gonna be just the
derivative of this little guy
which is negative, we bring down the two,
negative two thirds of x.
So when we go ahead and
plug in x equals one
to see what it looks like
when we evaluate at this point
that's just gonna be equal
to negative two thirds.
So that tells us that a is gonna
have to be negative two thirds.
Now for similar reasons,
let's go ahead and compute the
partial derivative with respect to y.
We look down here, the
only place that y shows up
in the entire expression
is this negative y squared.
So the partial derivative
of f with respect to y
is equal to negative
two y, negative two y.
And now when we plug in
y equals negative two
what we get is negative two
multiplied coincidentally
by negative two, didn't
have to be the case
that those were the same, and
that whole thing equals four.
So the partial derivative
of f with respect to y
evaluated at this point one negative two
is equal to four.
So if we were to plug
this information back up
into our formula we would replace
a with negative two thirds.
It would say negative two thirds.
And we would replace b with
four, replace b with four.
And that would give us the full formula,
the full formula for the tangent plane.
And this can be kind of
a lot to look at at first
because we have to specify the
input point one negative two.
And then we had to figure out where
the function evaluates at that point.
And then we had to figure out both of the
partial derivatives with respect
to x and with respect to y.
But all in all, there's not actually
a lot to remember from how
you go about computing this.
Looking at the graph actually makes
things seem a lot more reasonable
because each of those terms
has an actual meaning.
If we look at the one and negative two,
that's just telling us the input,
the kind of x and y
coordindates of the input
and of course we have to evaluate that
because that tells us the z coordinate
that will put us on the graph
corresponding to that point
and then to get a tangent plane
you just need to specify the two bits of
partial differential information
and that will tell you how this graph
needs to be oriented,
and once you start thinking
of things in that way,
geometrically, even though
there's a lot going on here,
there's five different
numbers you have to put in,
each one of them feels like
of course you need that number
otherwise you couldn't
specify a tangent plane.
There's kind of a lot
of information required
to put it on the appropriate spot.
So with that I will see you next video.